yeah so um
i'm going to be speaking about
algorithms first pass instances of the
max sat problem uh this is based on
joint work with rov and chen
um so first define the problem um so the
max sat problem and then the special
case which is the max case that problem
you're given as input a cnf or a kcnf on
n variables
and you're asking for the maximum number
of
satisfiable clauses in the formula
um of course you could also have a
decision version of this where given an
additional parameter say r and asked if
there are at least our clauses that are
satisfiable but these two problems are
polynomial time equivalent so we'll be
considering this version through the
talk
and just some general notation through
the talk n will be a number of variables
in a formula and m will be the number of
clauses and k will be the clause width
and we'll be interested in this
parameter c which is a clause density so
we're interested in cases where the
formula is passed which means that c is
a constant so that's just a number of
clauses divided by a number of variables
um so the question is what are the best
um so we want to solve form exactly um i
mean of course there are good
approximate solutions um but we want um
exact solutions and we want to know what
kind of running time can achieve for
exact solutions to this problem
um
so generally speaking this definition of
savings of an algorithm will be useful
to kind of um present our results so um
for a problem it has savings s where s
is some function of m and n if there's
an algorithm running in time two to the
n minus s times volume of m
um so s is intuitively the amount of
savings of brute force search
so in general n is some parameter that
kind of represents the size of the
search space in this case the size of
the subspace is just the
number of possible assignments which is
2 to the n um so that's what we're
trying to save over um and you'll have
some additional factor which is
polynomial in the instance size which
we'll kind of be suppressing mostly
through the top we won't be that
interested in it um so we're interested
in achieving savings as large as
possible for this
for this problem
so
it's not hard to see that under the
strong exponential time hypothesis which
says that
well which for example implies that c
and f sat doesn't have savings omega n
that would also imply that max sat does
not have since omega n because max that
is a harder problem
than c and f sat so we can't really hope
for that in general
so if we want savings that's linear then
we somehow need to restrict the
instances that we consider
in some way
so there are a couple of natural
restrictions to consider one is to
actually restrict the clause width
so that's the max k side problem um
so
there's the theorem of
williams
that um
max 2 sat
is in time
2 to the omega n over 3.
where omega is an exponent of matrix
multiplication um in this particular
case it's i think
more
intuitive and natural to present the
actual exponent rather than the savings
because it's related to the experimental
matrix quantification but it's open how
to get linear savings for any k that's
bigger than two
so this is one of the major open
questions and exact algorithms
so this is a very interesting
restriction to get algorithms the exact
algorithms for max case at for k bigger
than two but we don't know how to do
that um in general with linear savings
um so we've been interested in the stock
instead and the other restriction which
is the restriction of the clause density
so we're looking at clause density
that's linear and we want savings in
terms of that
um
and and that's what we'll be achieving
here so there were such
savings known before which are linear
when the clause density is linear uh
it's just that our results are
improve on those in terms of parameters
um so
theorem
so um let's say the three parts to the
serum so the first part um
savings
omega n
over c
so there's a polynomial space algorithm
for which we can get savings omega of n
over c
and if you relax the the space
constraint and you'll have exponential
space then there's an algorithm that has
savings n o square root c
and in general um
if you have savings that's that's linear
for for for cases or for rsat then um we
get improved savings um for cnfs that
with the velocity c
so savings
um
omega of delta n
foreign
um okay so delta um
is is kind of some kind of linear
savings for k sat but this delta might
of course depend on k
so the omega here is a factor which
doesn't depend on k um and i'm trying to
capture the savings that you get for for
max sat as a function of the delta and c
and k yeah
um
so
well
this result b here follows from from c
by setting k equals two because there's
linear savings for for max two sat so uh
the c is essentially a reduction in
general from um
for maxi instances with cn clauses to um
um to do case sat instances um and and
the larger and if you get linear saying
for larger k you get better and better
savings for for for uh max that with cn
clauses
um if there's anything that's unclear at
any point feel free to interrupt
okay so um those are our results um
and now i'm going to talk about the
general kind of algorithmic technique we
use and the analysis technique which is
maybe more interesting than the
algorithmic technique um so it's it's a
very well studied well perhaps the most
well-studied argument technique which is
branching um so let me just kind of
present a certain kind of view of
branching algorithms so suppose you're
um you want to design a branching
algorithm for
for for cns for let's say for ksat then
in some sense you want to explore the
tree of assignments
so um
let me represent
a branching tree in this way so you have
and so on and then you have um the
leaves
so you have a tree and the north of the
stream are labeled with the formula at
which you're calling um the algorithm so
initially calling the algorithm the
formula fee um and you somehow choose a
variable to branch on so you set the
variable to zero and explore the space
of assignments for the variable set to
zero um and then if you don't find a
satisfying assignment there you set the
variable to one and explore the space of
those assignments
um and you and you do this recursively
until somehow this formula fee
simplifies to the extent that you can
solve it in some easy way
right um and we'll describe how the
simplification works uh shortly um so so
the variables here just represent the
variables you're branching on at each
stage
um and and what would simple mean to us
well simple mean that the way the
formula actually simplifies to a
constant that is either identically zero
identically one because then of course
you know whether the formula is
satisfiable or not so this is kind of
one version of a branching paradigm for
uh for satisfiability
um so
when you design a branching algorithm
there are there are kind of two aspects
to it one is actually designing the
branching heuristic or the branching
rule how do you choose variables at each
stage to set um and the second is how do
you simplify the formula right
so we're going to be considering like
very straightforward kind of
simplification rules simplification
rules um
so there are various complex branching
heuristics and supplication rules that
are used in literature but in this talk
we'll be concerned with very
straightforward ones
so the first one is um
um if
a literal in c in clause c uh is set
to one uh delete c
right so yeah that's
um that's obvious and if it's set to
zero then you just
delete the
literal
um and if a clause becomes empty
set fee
so the clause becomes empty that means
it's unsatisfiable and so you um you set
the whole formula to zero in that case
um
so
yeah i mean so these simplification
rules are very straightforward and it's
unclear that you can achieve anything
interesting using these simplification
rules and a branching heuristic but in
fact there's a very natural algorithm
which achieves asymptotically the best
savings we know for ksat just using
these simplification rules and a very
naive branching heuristic which is just
choose a variable at random at each
stage and set it at random right so
that's kind of a very kind of simple
algorithm um
at each stage the formula you pick a
variable at random set it at random
either to zero one and then explore the
space
recursively after simplifying the
formula in this way
this actually gives you savings omega of
n over k for k sat which is the best
known savings we know for case add up to
constant factor
so
it's kind of a folklore result um
so i should say that if you're
interested in the exact constant here
then there are better algorithms such as
the the potential lux zane algorithm
which gets you um actually constant
bigger than one here um but uh if you're
not internal constant then this is a
fairly simple algorithm which has a very
very simple branching algorithm which
has this performance
um and the proof of it actually goes
where i start switching lemma so um it's
kind of a it's kind of different from
the analysis of branching algorithms
in for graph theoretic branching
algorithms in the sense that it's not so
much local as global so
usually when you're trying to analyze a
branching algorithm you set up some
recurrence some fixed term recurrence
and then you solve the recurrence to get
an estimate on the number of leaves of
the tree
but
for case that it's not so clear how to
do this and instead you have some kind
of a global analysis
which bounds the size of the tree in a
different way
using certain concentration bounds um
and i'm not sure i have time to talk
about it for for ksat but i'll be
talking about something similar for max
sat um and that should give you the
general idea
um but i just want to present the
branching paradigm for for ksat and
well and we want to explore the
possibility of extending this to max sat
so this is something that solves k-set
but how do you extend it to max that
well i mean the main issue is that for
max at um this notion of a leaf doesn't
make much sense anymore because well if
the leaf is a one then of course the
formula satisfiable all clauses are
satisfiable but if it's a zero then
you're not getting information i mean
that's what you want to find out how
many clauses you can satisfy um so just
the fact that the formula is
unsatisfiable doesn't give you
information
so we need to have a different notion of
a leaf somehow
and
that also means that you need a
different notion of simplification rule
because this simplification rule is not
going to be helpful to us it's kind of
removing important information
so we're just going to modify this the
last implication rule three um
in
kind of a minor way and let's call it
three prime
and we'll just say um
well so um
yeah if c becomes empty we just delete c
um and the point is and now we also
change our notion of a leaf right so the
notion of relief earlier was that you
the function became a constant either a
zero or a one but now the notion of a
leaf will be that you have a one c and f
here
so um you have formulas which are one
cns
let's say a psi one
two
three
four and i is one cnn
so that will be a leaf the point is that
once you get to a one cnf solving max
status easy polynomial time
so
so there's two things the first is that
with this notion of a leaf you can solve
max hat and polynomial time for the leaf
but also you're preserving information
all along the tree as you're branching
because um well when
you're deleting a c for which the
literal set to one you keep track of the
fact that that clause is satisfied and
similarly when a clause is um gets
deleted because all the literals are
false you you keep track of the fact
that it's unsatisfied and thereby at any
node in the tree you know how many
clauses have been satisfied so far and
how many have been falsified so that um
at these leaves um you have a certain
number of clauses one one clauses and
for the rest of the clauses you know
whether they are satisfied or falsified
right
um so basically solving max fact for
each leaf is going to give you on the
solution for um for the max size for the
for the original instance v
so this is kind of the this is how
branching um
works for uh for for max hat
but with this simplification rule kind
of well a lot of the advantage we were
getting in this case um to get savings
omega n over k was from using this
multiplication rule that the function
became a zero um when when c became
empty uh because that was going to
happen with significant probability and
that's going to give us our advantage so
the fact that we've kind of um relaxed
the simplification rule so much is
unclear if they will get anything at all
now and this is somehow the inside of
this or this paper of
of sakai sector and tamaki which is the
predecessor of our paper which we build
on
and they show how to analyze the case
when
when they even use this simplification
rule so this is the result
from the sad conference last year um
so the branching rule is going to change
slightly and in fact it's going to um
be good in a way because algorithm will
now be determined sticker on the
randomized
so um
earlier the branching was random at
each node you just picked a variable at
random to branch on and now it's going
to be greedy you're just going to pick a
variable which occurs the maximum number
of times in your formula and branch on
that so that's going to be the branching
heuristic again a very simple branching
heuristic and also one that can
implement deterministically um and with
that branching heuristic and this kind
of modified certification rules they get
savings that's n over k squared c
squared for max k set so i should say
it's max k set here
next case set with c n clauses
um okay so that's the result so let me
give some idea now of the analysis and
of course the main lemma so this kind of
a global analysis which will perform um
on the tree on the on the recursion tree
in order to bounce the number of leaves
in it um
um so let's let me just say give you an
idea of how that works
so somehow kind of a key lemma a main
lemma here
is this kind of like concentration
result
um
so there exists a p
and
b prime
b and p prime less than one
so now look at depth kind of p times the
end of the recursion tree right so you
have um some parameter p and you look at
all the nodes at depth p times n so
there's a set of nodes here
you look at look at these nodes um and
you look at the formulas that occur
these nouns right the formulas that
correspond to the to recursive calls at
those nones
um yeah so let's say you know v i one
um so you want that with high
probability that some event happens here
and that the high priority event is that
there's going to be very few um nodes
which have lots of clauses that don't
want clauses right and you want this
event to happen with very high
probability
so now fee i um
yeah so
probability or i guess the choice of r
from nodes of the tree so r is in a
level
v n
the vr um
and via
um
has
so
okay so um so this is kind of like the
the lemma that can analyze their their
analysis
so um at some fixed p lesson one um if
you look at all the nodes um in the
recursion tree at that depth um and if
you look at the formulas corresponding
to those nodes then um the probability
that
that's a randomly chosen formula at that
level has more than this many clauses
with width larger than one is
exponentially small and this is kind of
a
a key element you need this property to
be exponentially small
um
so let me say why this is good so why
does this give us an algorithm with
linear savings and then maybe i'll just
give you some very very rough intuition
on why something like this holds
so um the reason that this gives us kind
of linear savings is that okay so you
can look at two kinds of nodes right the
good nodes so the nodes that um satisfy
um the complement of this event and the
bad notes the notes for which this is uh
um this is true well the bad notes have
exponentially small probabilities so
there's going to be only two to the
minus omega p prime n fraction of them
and if you just do brute force search
and all such nodes you're not going to
spend time more than two to the n minus
p p prime times n so the savings
corresponding to these bad nodes is
going to be omega of p prime times n
um and as for the good nodes what you
can do is you can just look at these
clauses that are bad these clauses that
have width bigger than one and each of
these clauses is going to be a size at
most k so you can just look at all
literals in these clauses and branch on
all of them um but that's not gonna be
too expensive because you'll only branch
on one minus p minus p prime times n
variables so the total number of
variables that you would have branched
on well p times n to start off with and
then one minus p minus p prime times n
here so there'll still be p prime times
n variables left which essentially
you're saving i mean that's the savings
of the algorithm so in either case
you're saving p prime times n and just
by setting p prime equals one over c
squared k squared and setting p
appropriately um you get the um
the result that sakai said on tamaki
have
and as for some intuition why this kind
of like strong constitutional result
holds well it's because somehow the when
you look at the cnf as a formula it kind
of shrinks um quite significantly when
you um
when you set variables in greedily so
when you set variables greedily to zero
and one the size of the formula is going
to shrink significantly with high
probability in fact it's going to shrink
so much that there's gonna be very few
clauses of of width greater than one um
so that's kind of the technical uh kind
of result lemma that underlies the proof
but yeah once you show that you get kind
of the analysis
the result that they have
um so how do we improve on this so um
one one issue here is the presence of k
so we want algorithms for k set rather
than if you want arguments for max sat
in general rather than max case that um
they have an algorithm for max at in
general by reducing to k equals log c
but there's an extra step and we kind of
do away with that and in fact somehow
naturally we shouldn't require to do
that we should be able to work directly
with clauses rather than with um with
cnfs formulas um counting the literal
size
um so so this is one this is one issue
and also there's the dependency squared
and the way we get around that is using
kind of an approach which is quite um
quite traditional and in branching
albums just a measure and conquer
approach so um
essentially um what we do is we we
assign um a measure um to the formula so
measure mu and the measure for a formula
is just going to be the sum or clauses
and the formula of
of mu of c where c is a clause
and the measure of clause is only going
to depend on the length of the clause
right so um the measure of a clause is
going to be
some sigma size c and we're going to
choose the sigma i's appropriately to
kind of um factor in our knowledge of
what we can do for max sat for um
for for wave for various clause widths
so um yeah i mean this is an approach
that's used quite often in branching
albums to somehow identify the right
kind of parameter to make progress on so
measure the way to identify the right
parameter to make progress on but quite
often this progress is measured in a
local way and i guess the difference
here is that we measure this progress in
a global way using these concentration
results but uh it's the same kind of
idea
and and basically for this algorithm a
here um we're going to set
um
so yeah so mu 1 is going to be 0 because
for max one side we can solve it in
polynomial time and then the mu is going
to increase after that and then uh mu i
is going to be equal to 2 for i
greater than equal to 2.
um so this is just kind of a branching
algorithm where we're going to reduce
everything to once one c and f of the
leaf
um but we can do something different
using the fact that
that max two sat is
um in time two omega n o3 that we have
savings there so we don't have to
um
have leaves that are
um that are one cns we can have leaves
that are two cns and then apply williams
algorithm um
and that would correspond to a different
choice of measure so that would
correspond to
mu 1 equals 0 and mu 2 as well equals 0
because we can do something non-trivial
for max 2 c and f for 2 c and s and then
we have mu 3 equals 1
and mu 4 equals 2 and
mu i equals 3 for
and so on so this is kind of like a
generic approach which which given um
like some good algorithm for ksat um
will give kind of an algorithm for um
for max sat in general with cn clauses
um with non-trivial savings so if you
just kind of um
extend this kind of measured approach we
get we get these kinds of savings here
yeah so um
so basically our algorithm is quite
similar in spirit to um to the sake of
tamaki algorithm it's slightly different
but the spirit is similar is we kind of
optimize analysis a bit more and we find
a way of kind of reducing in general to
um to
ksat um
okay
so any questions um yeah maybe i'll just
mention one more thing that this kind of
like um measure based approach actually
gives us something interesting from c
and f sat as well so um we get um
there's not the paper but it can easily
be
shown using the techniques in the paper
there's the branching algorithm
for cnfsat
with savings
omega one over log c
so there are arguments known for cnf set
of sayings omega one over log c but
these algorithms don't branch on
variables they have to branch on
disjunctions or other functions of the
variables but um somehow implicit in
approach is kind of a different way of
reducing from from cnf set to to bounded
with cnfsat which is based purely on
branching of variables and that can be
used to get an algorithm which is a
purely branching algorithm for cnf set
and this kind of idea might
maybe have some implications that are
interesting in other contexts such as
specification um which which remain to
be explored
um and i think another interesting
question is just to limit to kind of
explore the limitations of branching for
optimization in some sense
branching should be much less powerful
for optimization than for solving case
set exponentially less powerful in some
sense and maybe there's a way using
proof complexity to formulate this and
to show this
so that's that's on the problem that's
all
thanks
yep
so these savings for uh
sad that are implied by your algorithm
do they match the best savings yeah yeah
yeah they're the same
if i remember correctly they also have
some savings for a circuit
satisfiability with certain density can
you use the same
um well not for circuits in general do
you mean bounded depth circuits i think
boundary depths yeah with the densities
yeah that's right yeah i mean yeah we
could we could match that as well yeah i
mean we've got to kind of use our kind
of with reduction technique and there's
kind of a um a concentration result due
to hostile a newer concentration result
which which gives kind of the right
parameters to apply this so yeah we
could get that as well
anymore
maybe i can have fun
so
i was just wondering during the talk uh
are there any like hypotheses or
conjectures regarding the sizes of
savings that you can get for different
varieties of microsoft or cns stuff
which would be like
something like strengthening of uh
strokey th so is it uh investigated
it hasn't been investigated but it's a
natural thing to do when especially
considering that something like the
reduction from cnfsat to orthogonal
vectors kind of preserves things exactly
right so you could kind of look at more
refined savings um
yeah and in which case you need even
more fine grain reductions to study this
um but i think well it's not clear how
many people even believe that omega n
over k is the best savings you can get
or n or log c so
when belief in that is not very strong
maybe uh it's not clear whether to make
that conjecture
yeah or actually our intuitions that we
can't do better we need to confirm the
maybe study that longer before uh for
studying such
things okay
yeah so let's thanks again